thank you for seeing me Broadway history
was made not once but twice at the 2023
Tony Awards yes Alex Newell and Jay
Harrison G became the first two openly
non-binary performers to win and the
Tony goes to
you yes Alex was awarded with the
coveted Tony for best featured actor in
a musical for the role of Lulu in the
Broadway show shocked making them the
first openly non-binary performer to win
a Tony for active
I have wanted this my entire life
I should not be up here as a queer
non-binary fat black little baby from
Massachusetts
to anyone that thinks that they can't do
it I'm going to look you dead in your
face that you can do anything you put
your mind to Lee fans were over the moon
for Alex's win with the actor having
played the Beloved role of unique in the
hitbox show and the Tonys also saw a
mini Glee reunion as Leah Michelle took
the Tony stage to perform Don't Rain on
My Parade from funny girl
nobody is
[Music]
meanwhile Jay Harrison G became the
first non-binary performer to win the
Tony for best lead actor in a musical
further performance as Jerry Daphne and
Some Like It Hot
for every trans non-binary gender
non-conforming human whoever
was told you couldn't be you couldn't be
seen this is for you yes we love to see
queers winning big especially during
pride month what was your highlight from
this year's Tony Awards let us know in
the comments below